Here's the rest of the data.
We increase the force and the time it takes to go 10 m goes down.
We keep mass fixed at 10 kg the entire time.
This is a 2-part quiz.
I want to know how acceleration depends on force and mass.
I want you to choose the best option.
The way you're going to do that is by completing this table,
though you don't have to enter anything in,
and determining how does acceleration scale with force.
I think it's a tricky problem, but you can do it.
You'll probably need this equation to calculate the acceleration,
and once you've filled this out on your own, you should be able to calculate
how acceleration scales with force.
Is it proportional to 1/F, proportional to the force itself, or something else.